i'm clicking the start button so you'll
have about 10 seconds until
it starts
you are live chat brilliant right
good evening everybody my name is
andy crump um welcome to
tonight's virtual meeting of planning
committee b
and i will be chairman for this meeting
um
i'll need to go through the usual
housekeeping
again members you will be provided with
the council's etiquette for virtual
meetings in advance of this meeting
however just to reiterate the main
points
one please ensure your device is fully
charged or is charging
two please mute microphones when not
speaking
three please indicate in the chat bar if
you wish to speak
or want to invite you to address the
committee please ensure your microphone
is switched on
and switch off immediately once you're
finished
five please ensure you have switched off
or to sign
any other devices that you have that may
interrupt the proceedings
if any member encounters i.t problems
causing them to drop out of the virtual
meeting
they should use the best endeavors to
rejoin as quickly as possible
should the member be unable to rejoin
the meeting
they will be deemed to have left the
meeting at that point
and the meeting will continue provided
it remains correct
please note that the meeting is being
broadcast
live i just emphasize that being
broadcast live
and members of the public are able to
view the proceedings
i can confirm that checks been made to
ensure that all members of the committee
are in attendance and have confirmed in
the presence of the council's legal
officer that they can see and hear the
proceedings
also present online with me are offices
from democratic services
legal and planning thank you very much
and public speakers will be given a
30-second warning
during their speaking time once i
finished speaking the committee may
wish you to ask you questions so please
remain in the meeting
if there are no more questions you can
leave the meeting and
continue to watch the live proceedings
via the broadcast voting
when planning committee members vote
could they please
ensure they identify ourselves clearly
and speak into the microphone
so that their vote is understood clearly
by both
other members of the committee and also
those watching the webcast members
should respond
for against or abstain
thank you for that we now move
on to the agenda and the first item on
the agenda is the apologies
um have we received any we've got
apologies from councillor rock
chairman thank you nervia
gender item two disclosures of interest
do any committee members have any
interest
that they would like to declare in
relation to items on the agenda
uh just uh i shall be speaking on the
item of high house farm
you're speaking as yeah registered
speakers yes
yes yeah and you'll be
um yeah that's fine not a problem
and again it's in the update sheet that
several members of the community
actually
paid a site visit to to that location
thank you uh right
any other disclosure than just anybody
else
um i will be reading out uh
um someone uh an email from
councillor bromwich on
the acorn stores country street saturn
the one on holiday but
it was here for the original one meeting
when he got
deferred because we run out of time so i
will be reading that
uh i don't think anything else any other
no right good two items already moving
swimly
it's not even five past six how about
that uh
tick another one off the list uh do
other proposal and second up for the
minutes
of the meeting held on the 29th of july
2020 at catch the
field and i can see that you're
indicating to propose and cancel harvey
you're indicating to second that
uh right we now do need to do a roll
call
to whether we accept those in line with
the proposal by cancer fielding
councillor crump or casamel's
oh counseling has been muted counselor
mills for
councillor fielding four councillor
fleming
joshua fleming four captains mojave
council harvey four counts for hampshire
seraphin
influential seraphin iv and cancer
kettle
counselor kettle four thank you
right i will now have a slight change in
running order
and i'd like to with your agreement
bring application which is item number
six application number nineteen slash
zero one one six one slash fuel the
stable zero of little
lad brook farm and nine tamil wickenard
and i'm not to bring that one forward
and the reason for that one i just need
to make sure i am
reading the right one so i'll go to the
agenda places myself
yeah the reason why that was brought to
committee was because of the parish
council objection
uh the parish council have not
registered to speak at this meeting
and unusual process we normally
vote to see if we can delegate this one
to officers
so um firstly i want uh
approval from yourselves to bring this
item forward
uh do we need to do a roll call for that
one have yeah
no you can just agree to bring it
forward and then
propose or get some
so we'll bring that one forward um
and now uh i'm looking for somebody
for a proposed that we delegate this to
officers
uh cancer the mills proposes
i've got a secondary cancer hunter
surrogate thank you
so the proposal is to
delegate this application to offices as
uh
usual practice because the reason why it
was brought to the community was a
parish council objection
and they have not registered to speak
right sorry councillor can i just add to
that um the update
in the update sheet as well we've got um
a duplication that's going to be removed
yeah you know thank you so cancer
or cancer mouse
four cancer building council of fielding
for
councillor fleming councillor fleming
for
council harvey that's the harvey full
council seraphin
thank you sorry chad that's six
four and one abstention yep thank you
committee resolves to delegate
application nineteen
slash zero one one six one slash ful
to officers for uh their approval
thank you right
another one off the list and it's still
only eight minutes plus six
let's take that one off and we'll now
move
on to our next item on the agenda it's
application
number 20 slash treble 0
58 slash adv
acorn stores 75 to 76 country street
save them
hello all right i've been heckled
that's the good things about virtual
meetings and only virtual heckles so
that's okay
um and i'll move on to ryan who will be
presenting this application
thank you ryan good evening
right can everyone see that now yes i
can see that ryan thank you perfect
um the application site lies in the
heart of the southern town center and is
an existing commercial premises
as denoted by the black dot
advertisement consent is sought for a
new fascia
and a hanging sign to an existing
commercial premises
on the building the proposed fascia is
to be painted grey
with the lettering in white
the previous occupiers this shows the
previous
scheme which has since been removed
so the green and the white um and just
showing
other um commercial premises with
commercial signage
uh in the immediate vicinity
during the course of the application it
was brought to my attention
that the proposed
advertisements had been installed to the
premises
as shown in these photos it was further
brought to my attention that the
uh proposed works were not were
not done in accordance to the uh
approved drawings
prior to committee i have got
um approved confirmation
that the application if it were to be
approved that they would
revert to the as submitted drawings
with the application which would see the
removal of the black
uh trim and it will just retain the gray
with white lettering
and that's it yeah yeah
so um you haven't got any updates on
that on the update you should have a
ryan no no great thank you very much
move on to our first speaker uh mr tony
asprey
thank you mr asprey you've got can you
hear me all right sir
yes i found chairman and uh i've unmuted
my phone
you've got three three minutes um don't
feel obliged to use them all if you
don't need to
and please stay on the line so you can
ask any questions
far away when you're ready please thank
you so
committee the design before you has been
arrived at after a lengthy process of
consultation
to which the applicant has sought to
respond positively proactively
and flexibly initially the signage
design included additional lighting and
a change of color palette
uh including the applicant's uh
corporate scheme of lyle at black and
white
there have been no objections from
technical or statutory consultees
a single objection was received from a
member of the public regarding the
projecting sign
and the ward councillor councillor
bromwich made objections regarding the
color and size of the signage
and also the projecting side after
consideration of consultation responses
the design was amended
to present a scheme that closely echoes
premises signage exemplars
in the immediate area of the site and
respond even more closely to the
character of southern conservation area
the colour scheme proposes a tasteful
subdued light and dark grey composition
with individual silver metal coloured
lettering applied to a painted feature
that closely aligns with section h of
the design guide updated
only last year the additional lighting
proposals have been removed
and the fascia will now be downlit
externally utilizing the retained
existing
dark gray painted lighting trough above
the fascia
the proposals do not present a departure
in style from several existing
high street frontages along coventry
speed overall the proposals before you
are a reduction in the amount of
lettering
and advertising material that was
previously displayed on the acorn stores
frontage
and i submit are a material improvement
over the previous signage
with positive visual contribution to the
character of the conservationist
i submit therefore that the amended
plans before you are entirely
appropriate
and consistent with stratford-on-haven's
core strategy
policy cs9 and part h of the development
requirement spd
specifically relating to shock frontage
design and signage
accordingly members i commend the
well-reasoned officer report
recommending that express consent be
granted to you
thank you chairman right
annie all right thank you for that mr
raspberry um
any questions to
the agent
can't please anybody
anybody um i've got it's the screen i
can only see you ryan and myself at the
moment
i can't say anything through the chat
um right i've got a couple of questions
mr raspberry
one um you might not need to ask but
um answer but uh i might get ruled out
by
the legal officer um so i'll leave that
one to the second one
first one why was um the black trim
done in advance of the approval um just
wondered why that was done that was
different to the submitted
drawings uh it's quite a simple answer
uh and these things happen chairman uh
the contractor
uh got got it wrong the painting
contractor got it wrong
and did the wrong color scheme okay
that's fine
and you may know that i'm a neighbouring
ward member
for this one um and obviously
that there's the the box on the front
there's where the financial services
entrance going to be do you know how
long that's going to be therefore
because obviously
that's a bit of a better to keep them
with the rest of the frontage
sorry could you repeat that gentleman i
wasn't quite clear what you were asking
yeah i'm i'm neighboring ward member and
obviously you know that
area very well uh obviously obviously
the the second unit is going to be
financial services isn't it or something
similar
uh yeah and there's an entrance why it's
sort of been boxed off with a with a
brown
brown wood sorry grey grey wood entrance
i just wondered when that entrance
is likely to be opened properly and
because that
just appear out of keeping with the rest
of the street scene
uh my instructions are councilor that um
you know as soon as there is a tenant uh
to occupy it uh that'll be opened up uh
and they will no doubt apply for their
own signage
brilliant that's good that's that's all
i need to know our compressor on to
to the resistance to say them and i hope
you didn't think that was an
inappropriate question
not at all no brilliant any any further
questions for the
the agent
no right mr asprey you're free to go
thank you
thank you uh i will obviously
the cancer brothers award member isn't
here because he's on the holiday but he
did
uh leave me something for last time's
meeting that we didn't get around to
i'll very
briefly read earlier statements i wish
to object to this application
on the following grounds the area falls
within the conference
conservation area of save them but
they're already been a co-op store as
well as the
funeral partner co-op signage already
counts around about a quarter of the
signage in the area any more cult
signage would be overbearing contacts
with the area
and could place competition at a
disadvantage in regards to the funeral
basis i
see no demonstrable need for a new
illuminated sign especially as the very
large shop front
which is the top advertises funeral
services
with the very large imposing
battleship craig scheme which is
not in context for the surrendering
retail units i believe this
is not in keeping with the core strategy
policies in regards to vibrant turn
centers
a funeral power as the largest retail
unit in the center of the town is not
welcoming
so that's what i've got in front of me
so after that council bromish's
statement i won't be answering any
questions on that
that was his statement when i agreed to
read that
right um well i think it's no time to
move on for
questions for the officer um any items
of confirmation or clarification
no uh move on to
the debate then please who wants to
start on this one
and i i put forward a question oh
you're not reading very well i think no
i was trying to
do several things at the same time john
and as a member
i'm not good at multitasking you're a
man that's right
so
the color of the the gray color is that
in keeping is that the same color as was
available on the acorn stores or is it
a different shade of gray
you mean the the original because it was
an original it was green
green originally john before then the
co-op took it over
and got the images that we've got at the
acorn store share them
that was great i like gray yeah
ryan jordan put that back up yeah
yeah so
so when the application came to me this
year
that was the previous tenant's
um signage and coloring which is like
green and white
it was green was it it looks like gray
on the on the
screen oh okay but yeah recently the
caravan works
slightly different to what they're
seeking approval for
which is gray and black thank you
no problem catch the mills you want to
come in please
uh sorry mr chairman i was actually
coming in on on the debate not for
clarification
sorry yeah anybody else want to come on
we finished on clarification we were
happy on that one
happy for going to the bank catch the
mills if you want to start the debate
please
oh thank you mr yeah um
i'm not look to his site obviously um
and uh yeah the great degree is rather
imposing but
um i think the one of the objections was
the hanging sign but
um looking along from there along the
roadway
i think connells have a hanging sign so
it's not so there aren't any hanging
signs in
um in southam um
and it looked it looks you know
there's also the um the shop next door
i mean it's got all the goods outside so
you know they that stands out quite some
way
um so at the moment mr chairman i have
no problems with the um this application
mr chairman thank you if i listen to
what everybody else has to say first
thank you anybody else want to come in
on this
here's the feeling
you're muted still that's for that
um i've got no objection to the the
black and gray
it's it's uh otherwise it's just an
imposing battleship color
and i'd rather that we had the two tones
and i would propose that we allow as it
is at the moment
okay harvey do you want to come in
though you've indicated please
uh yes this seems to me to be a very
open and shut case the officers made a
clear recommendation
it's been discussed uh i'm quite happy
with it
uh as proposed the agents made a clear
case
it's in line with uh with core strategy
uh can we get on with it i propose that
we
approve
thank you right then um ross i might
need your assistance on this um i'm not
sure whether kent's the field in my
proposal as well um but his proposal was
different
to the actual original application
no he can't propose something that isn't
before us so i'd disregard that
and go with councillor harvey's proposal
happy with that
right thank you for that russ that's um
and i've just been told that cancer
cattle will second cancel the harvey
um so the proposal and the second uh uh
we'll go to the vote then please
which is to grant the application us
set in the papers sorry olivia so now
jump in the gun there councillor cramp
four councillor mills
council meals for cancer building
cancer fielding for
chair thank you uh
committee resolves to grant application
twenty slash
zero zero zero fifty eight slash adb
acorn stores
thank you thank you everybody thank you
ryan thank you
all right we all know do we need a
little gap
in between um are we okay to move on i
don't know
i know in the past we've had a slight
gap between the applications
speakers so
i think
i think yeah if you um if we're back by
about
26 minutes past if that's okay then i
think
that we've got to get these speakers in
um
mills so a little bit of a delay but
we'll keep this as limited as possible
i'll turn up
whilst we're muted if anybody's there
can you hear me it's victoria chadway
it's just that uh i've have internet
issues so hopefully
i'm now connected to a better wi-fi
no no we can't hear you victoria
[Laughter]
i'll take that as a positive
i'm happy
it's been on the phone to um the
objector
counselor rickards um he will be joining
the meeting now he's just gonna dial in
so i think maybe um if we start
and maybe move the objectives until he's
in last
if that's okay yep that's fine yeah
we've um his councilor cody and okay
from
mapo he is yeah
right okay we'll start
um i'll bang my double again
um adam you're okay for us to um
yeah brilliant right we'll move
on i'll put my
camera back on so you can see i'm on
with you in spirit anyway
um move on to our next item on the
agenda which is twenty slash
zero zero five two one slash fuel
high house farm birmingham road map over
a green studly
demolition of existing buildings and
redevelopment of the site to erect a
purpose-built care home c2 use class
for older people with associated access
parking and
landscaping and our presenting officer
is victoria hello victoria good evening
good evening chair can i just check you
can see the presentation
not a moment we can see you okay bear
with me
there we go can you see it now yes thank
you perfect
great thank you so the application
is for a 66 bed c2 use care home
on the high house farm site as indicated
by the black dot
this is a more immediate context slide
of the application site um the red
dotted line
being the boundary for red edge
redditch's
administrative boundaries so everything
to the left is within redditch and
everything to the right
is within our own administrative demise
this is um a google image of the site
showing the site in context the site
is um highlighted in blue the orange
line
i'm afraid that's my crude
interpretation so it's not probably 100
accurate but to show where the the
boundary of redditch is
and you can see that the site is in a
fairly mixed area with lots of
commercial properties
to the um east of the application site
and there is a residential two-story
residential property to the south of the
site
and cluster of bungalows also to the
south of the warwick highway
the site's just off of a traffic island
as indicated
um i don't know if you can see my cursor
let me just turn that on to
there we go that's probably better uh a
traffic island here serving the a
um four three five so the birmingham
road the a1
the a4 189 which is the henley road and
obviously
warwick highway over here there's a
number of garden centers
um a harvester pub restaurant and
another restaurant and petrol filling
station to the south of the site
the next image if you can see my cursor
i was standing where the cursor is
now and that's looking at the site and
the access
over here to give a bit more context
or policy context to the site on the
left hand side of the screen
is the built-up area boundaries as shown
in the site
allocations plan these are in draft at
the moment
um the site actually falls within this
middle section
and so on the right hand side i've blown
that up and tried to show
where the application site is outlining
in blue
as far as the draft built-up area
boundary
is concerned there's a small parcel of
the application site that falls
slightly outside of the built-up area
boundary which
i've highlighted in yellow
this is an extract from redditch borough
council's local
plan which is adopted uh i've indicated
the site to the south uh here shown in
blue
this pink's wave is a housing allocation
in the redditch local plan for 205
dwellings
so that kind of gives an indication as
to perhaps the future context
of the character of the area whilst
that's currently open it is allocated
for housing
this is an extract from our own draft
site allocations plan again
and to the east of the application site
are two reserved uh proposed reserved
housing
allocations going forward so again um
gives an indication to perhaps the
future context of the area
uh turning to the the site itself uh
this is um the plan formats for the
proposed care home which would be
set back from the existing access um
relatively centrally within the site uh
there are a number
the whole site is covered by a blanket
tpo
so that all of the trees on site would
be retained as proposed by the
application
there's the existing hedgerow to um
parts of the site and where that exists
that's proposed to be retained
the application proposes in addition to
the care home
landscaping to surround it and parking
on-site for up to 24 vehicles including
some electric
vehicle charging points the access would
be altered
to enable left in left out into the site
which is stone
slightly better here and has been
submitted as part of the transport
statement
and would be dealt with via marketings
on the
on the access here's the elevations for
the proposal the southern elevation is
the front elevation
um uh to the site that there's proposals
to in it well
the elevation show gables
this is proposed to be brick with some
render and then some wood cladding
just to articulate gables and a
red tile roof albeit materials aren't
detailed in the submission and would be
proposed for condition if that's how
members wanted to proceed
and this is um just a cgi to show
to show that in slightly more context
for um context of the existing area this
is the house that's immediately to the
south of the application site so it's
the two-story dwelling
um with red brick and red tiles
this is the bungalow opposite the site
this is the harvester restaurant on the
opposite side of the road
chairman the recommendation is to grant
subject to a legal agreement for the
capital contribution
of 14 920 pounds for primary medical
care facilities for the improvement of
the extension of
the pool medical center and it's
recommended
with a number of conditions including
an update to condition 16 as detailed in
the update sheet
thank you thank you victoria
um we'll know move on i believe all our
speakers are here now
and hopefully our first speaker shall be
catch that steve curley from
maplewood green parish council and i
believe you're the chairman mr carly
councillor carly um would you like to
come in now please
cancer county can you hear us
if you press star 6 to unmute
hello
councillor coley are you with us
i can see that he's on the call chairman
um council coley if you press star six
on your phone and that will unmute you
okay i think i'll be on muted now yes we
can
yep uh right then councillor coley um i
believe you're chairman of the
muppet green paris council is that
correct yes i
am you've got three minutes we'll give
you a warning with 30 seconds to
go and please stay with us because there
may be some questions from the committee
to you
far away when you're ready please right
the planning application for this
property was turned down
by the highways in 2015 as being too
dangerous
for a few houses as you cannot see
oncoming traffic to your right as you
leave the bend
now a few years later on it's deemed to
be okay for a
60 plus nursing home with 20 plus
parking spaces bus delivery plus
transport plus staff
plus visitors with only 20 car parking
places
the car park has been put where there
were no houses to be built and this land
is green belt
and should not be built on the boundary
isn't where it shows on the drawings
unless she's told us
ragebound is further back and ready to
go out 30 foot of trees
before they can even build anything
when previous planning was granted there
was for less traffic
going around the island which is only a
few meters
away from the entrance ie a huge
distribution depot for amazon
with 200 plus bloody parking spaces
which in turn
would equate to approximately 200 watts
on my delivery vans
could be in and out of the warehouse if
half go north and half go south
100 vans going really silent uh you know
one out
one in the sunday going back to reload
that's 200 a day
do the planners know that there are now
two lots of children pedestrian
crossings
one on the white road and one on the
birming road and children go to school
at the same time as people go to work
there are in the next few years to be
over 200 thousands built
on that half a mile from the island not
next to the nursing home where he stated
as much over the green is a cons
apparently is a category four
service village there are no footpaths
along the wall
highway in either direction or any
public transport
the nudist bus stop is half a mile away
plus walk from a proposed
nursing home the care plan recommends
houses for mappable green the core plan
sorry
it recommends houses for mappable green
not commercial buildings
which will choke the village it is time
for the planets to listen to the people
of the parish because we muppet green
and in a green we are all in an area of
a quarter
mile from this proposed nursing home we
have three gardeners there's a garage a
chinese restaurant
a big pub a children's school we don't
want or need
a 60 bedroom care home um
i would also thought that the air
pollution is going 30 seconds chairman
the air pollution is going to get very
very near
to the danger area and this is only 50
metres from the proposed
mercy gun thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor curly well within
time
right um let's have a quick look who
wants to ask
some questions um first of all it's
councillor harvey please
look out for harvey you're muted
trevor we can't hear you thank you
pardon
that's a good job thank you um is it in
order to ask a
question of the officer uh not
no i think we'll have yeah have to be um
as part of the points of clarification
with officer
um yeah this spits just any
any local knowledge of the area
um and if there's any discrepancies
in their opinion that the councillor's
opinion
to to the report now please pass on
thank you catch the mails
um good evening uh councillor um
uh i was listening to your um statement
did you say uh something about the the
neighborhood development plan have have
you got one
so are you speaking to me there yes i am
sorry yes
do you do you have an ndp
of the corps plan no the neighborhood
develop
do you have a neighborhood development
plan or a parish plan
a parish plan no we don't have a parish
plan no
no i um and uh this if i may ask again
uh mr chairman um
were you consulted by the uh the
applicant
was the priority council consulted
no the concern i've never i'm
they've never spoken to us the nursing
home or anybody we just had their
planners come through
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you thank you
um catch the kettle can you come in
please
thank you mr chairman um councillor um
you raised concerns um about the highway
impact of this
site but we have heard from the officer
in her presentation
that it is a left turn in and left turn
out
um and i do know the junction i used to
work for some time just around the
corner from there
um and i appreciate it is a
heavily trafficked area but
with that constraint does that
make you feel any more comfortable that
you won't have any vehicles
crossing the carriageway to get in or
out of the site
i jumped in
hello can i speak now yeah sorry cancer
cody come on in
we lost you for a second yes feel free
to answer that please
yes this was talked about this when it
was going to be houses 10 houses there
to turn left out you'd have to put
bollards in the road to stop people
cutting across as they come around there
delivery drivers and people
don't observe this as you find out in
the aldi
uh in studly it's there's a big other
saying you must turn left
i should think 30 percent of the people
still turn right i think it's it's just
something bit of them
and i don't think that will work to be
honest
you've got a question please and can you
mute your
yes i'm on muted um
you refer to some of it being in the
green belt
i was under the impression that none of
it was in the green belt
the the piece which was in yellow and it
was on on the drawings
that when they applied for the houses
they didn't apply to build any houses on
that particular piece
because i thought they couldn't get
permission on it because it was a green
belt although they owned it
they weren't going to be granted
permission to build this so these are
one behind the house
that's there exactly
is that green belt or green field i
think it's green belt
i'm almost sure it is it shows the
boundary
it shows the reddish boundary coming
right around the building but it doesn't
and even if it was redditch have got to
give under the the latest um
ombudsman rules at least 30 meters
of trees before they can start building
so the houses will not be right up to it
as it shows
yeah thank you for that uh councillor
currently we'll again we'll we'll check
with officers um where they got the
information from and
the uh how valid that that statement is
so yeah thank you for that
um thank you before you go um
yeah have you as a
parish done a um village design
statement or
uh no no we're just making sure we've
covered the
ndp um paris plan or
british design so no i was just uh
making sure we got all
all three of them covered um well we're
only a small punish
precinct of 13 000 pounds um we didn't
expect
houses we need nursing homes we don't so
we didn't see this one probably
otherwise we might have arranged
something differently but it's too late
now
yeah the door's gone the horse has gone
but
this you've made your feelings known and
you've done the presentation
and you've written in as well so you can
feel proud that you've represented your
your parish well so
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you hold on before you go i've
just got another question
from cancer kettle is that is that for
the
thank you councillor thank you mr
chairman aye councillor um
you just said that uh you need houses
but not
um assisted or
extra care or nursing home cases
um i use it there is a
um a document submitted with the
planning application
um justifying the need to provide
um in in sort of probably the
inaccurate description extra care uh are
you
are you disagreeing with that are you
saying there is no need for
um age related
accommodation in your in where you live
well i'll just that's if sorry
sweetheart if i just answered
very very quickly and very easily if you
have a look
at jerome redditch magazines or
stratford
study ready redditch his own papers they
send out
there are 11 nursing homes applying for
people
yep okay thank you for advertising yeah
brian thank you very much cancer cody
thank you right uh our next speaker or
is catch the climb rickard councillor
cards are you with us please
that's the records that's the records if
you press star six to unmute yourself
well if you do it again i think you've
re-muted
hello can you hear me now yes we can
cancer oh grace
great i'm just i'm not used to being on
the end of just a phone when i'm at
these meetings
i have a very nice picture of the of you
chairman but it's frozen and
that's all i can see right um should i
continue
yes you've got three minutes i believe
you got have you got
somebody with you is it maureen no no um
no um uh councillor maureen berry of
mapper green
agreed that i should have the whole
three minutes allocation
for the two of us yeah and that that's
been agreed by officers
yeah no that's fine you've got okay
right
we'll give you a warning with 30 seconds
to go and please stay with us for any
questions from the committee okay
the construction of a car park and
gardens outside of the built
up area boundary clearly extends the
curtilage of the buab
and thereby compromises the integrity of
the open green spaces
and green belt policies while there are
no
precedents involved in planning
decisions this
encroachment has implications for the
future development of the area
the car park is proposed within 10
meters of the rear of the ashmount
residence
involving a diminution of the menaces in
respect of noise
light pollution and reduction in clean
air
given the effects of vehicles and a
negation of the right to a tranquil
and peaceful environment the fdc
core strategy has mappable green as a
category 4
service village and thereby small scale
schemes are allowed within the buab
or physical confines i submit this
proposal
exceeds these parameters
it could be argued by some that the plan
by redditch bc to build over 200 houses
on land to the north of this site
makes a defense of this green space
irrelevant
however the inspector making the
decision on this redditch development
clearly advocated a screening of
mappable green
from the allocated housing site
the greenbelt and open green space
policies
serve as further protection for mappable
green
from the allocated housing site and yet
here
is proposed an encroachment on that
separation zone
which is contrary to the intentions of
the aforementioned inspector
and sdc's greenbelt policy
finally planning policies as in agenda
page 23
i think this has been referred to
already a district and county level
make it clear that there is a preference
for housing with
extra care rather than so-called
institutional care provision
further it is the case that the proposal
would not make a contribution to
overall housing supply including
affordable housing thank you
thank you councillor rickards well
within time
right uh any questions for
the county councillor
right wasp people thinking i've got one
cancer rickard
um could you just clarify um
you mentioned was it the car park um
that would extend the cartilage
of the buab yes of the built-up area
i didn't quite catch that i didn't i
caught a bit of yeah the the boa
meaning the built up area boundary which
i'd referred to in the previous year
i know i know that bit sorry i know that
uab you were saying that
the actual car park will extend
and extend it uh further than it is now
um is that what you're saying and
hopefully yeah
um no i haven't got a note of that i've
seen the map but
unfortunately i didn't make that but
undoubtedly it does extend this and
i would contend thereby um
you know challenges as it were the the
open green spaces and
belt policies brilliant
thank you for that uh cancel the kettle
and you've just
indicated yeah thank you mr chairman
um councillor you counselor you've um
suggested this is um
inappropriate where it is for for the
reasons you outlined
um but as i i said earlier on this is a
site i know well having spent
many years driving past it and the
existing
um existing buildings are not exactly
um a positive addition i would suggest
the landscape and therefore something
needs to happen to this given it's got
its steel shutters around it
it doesn't really enhance anything um
do not do not see that this is this
proposal it may not be
the best proposal from your point of
view but it supposes going to improve
the uh the setting of the area
yeah but i i i didn't i didn't contend
in anything i said uh that the
existing um buildings
uh were as it were um an incentive to
read about the site or not i didn't make
any reference
to that um however i did i did uh
make part of my submission related to
the residence known as ashmount um
where i think you know there is a clear
challenge to the
in amenities terms to that residence but
yes
as to the old sort of farm buildings
i mean i wouldn't argue that in that
respect um
but it's seen you know with respect i'm
not sure
that's relevant to the argument that
i've just given
right thank you
any further questions i can't see any
right we'll thank you councillor ricardo
you're free to go but still
stay with us um thank you very much
which will now move on to the
agent our next speaker which i believe
is mr alistair wood
is that right have i got pronounced the
name correctly i've got the right person
mr wood
mr woodard can you hear us right
now yes we can hear you've got six
minutes mr wood we'll give you a warning
with 30 seconds
and again please stay with us for any
questions from the committee
far away when you're ready please okay
thank you
good evening chairman members of the
committee my name is aleister wood
i'm the planning and development manager
for the applicants
lnt care developments lnt are
specialist developers and operators of
care facilities for older people
and we have an excellent track record in
delivering high quality care and
excellent caring environments
over a significant period of time now
this site has been identified as a
suitable location for
development based on our detailed
analysis of the local area
independent specialist healthcare
consultants have also confirmed a clear
and demonstrable need for a new care
provision for all the people within this
area
and the proposed care home would be very
much a local community facility
with future occupants either already
resident within the local area
or dependence of persons already
resident within the local area
all future residents are expected to
have a local connection
in addition to delivering an important
and much needed community service
the development will also generate
between 50 to 60 jobs
almost all of which will be offered to
suitable candidates from the local area
and as such positively add to a
sustainable mix of development
within the area we think that the site
lies within the physical confines of map
over green
and has a history of approval for
development and is considered ideal to
accommodate the proposed care home
the application site has been approved
for development of 10 new dwellings
but currently has a somewhat deal its
appearance
it was important in our site selection
to note that the land
immediately north and northwest of the
site has been allocated by red explorer
for residential development and that the
land
to the immediate east and northeast is
proposed to be similarly allocated
within the emerging stratford local plan
proposed development is for a 66 bedroom
facility
seemed to be the necessary quantum of
development
in order to generate a viable modern
care home
capable of delivering the quality of
care and caring environment expected
in 2020
development within within the immediate
vicinity is already
of a notable notably mixed character
containing a series of sizable
commercial uses
set within expansive hard surfaced areas
in the form of nearby public house
pest refilling station and two large
garden centers
actual levels within the site are such
that the proposed new building would be
set at a level
slightly lower than the adjacent road
and the building itself
would not exceed a conventional
two-story two stories in height
as such it should not appear out of
place given the nature of development
already present
a great care has been taken in our site
planning and design
in order to retain existing and
important landscape features
all existing trees and hedgerows are to
be retained and
and energy new trees and hedgerows
planted
that will all assist in the assimilation
of the development within its surrounds
the built forum has generally been
located towards the eastern
side of the site in order to respect the
setting of the immediately neighboring
residential property with the existing
boundary treatments trees
and ponds retained and enhanced it
should serve to preserve the reasonable
privacy and immunity of the occupants of
that property
at this time in association with the
proposed care home there is expected to
be an expansive area of external
immunity space intended to provide
attractive landscape setting
but also important usable garden space
for future residents
went to to enjoy whenever possible
the proposed access has been designed in
a rigorous
and detailed manner in consultation with
specialist highways consultants
the design follows that approved in
relation to the previous release
development scheme for the site
and involves left-turn access in and out
manageable due to the proximity of both
nearby roundabout junctions
with regards to parking we are more than
confident that the level proposed is
satisfactory
this meets the locally adopted standards
in relation to the proposed use
and will be capable of satisfying
on-site demand
within normal day-to-day operational
circumstances
at all times the reason that
that we are confident in this respect is
based on our experience
having carried out several similarly
sized developments
in similar locations with a similar
level of parking
in which no parking issues are currently
present
it is noted also that no objection to
access or parking has been made by
either highways authority consulted on
this application
in terms of usage the car park will be
used on a relatively low intensity basis
that's given the nature of the use also
given an intended policy of no
restriction
on visiting times this means that while
there will be peaks and activity and
demand
none of these peaks will be particularly
great and importantly
none of these excesses in any way
proposed care home will also have strong
sustainability credentials
heating off the home will be provided by
way of a ground source
system that will provide in excess of 15
of the whole building's energy
requirement a multitude of others
measures are planned including low
energy lighting throughout
biodiversity enhancement amongst others
in conclusion
chairman proposed development is
considered broadly in accordance
development plan
satisfactory relative to other material
considerations non-balance
i feel agreeable in planning from a
planning perspective
and in these circumstances uh therefore
i'm respectfully requesting
support your officer's recommendation
grant planning commission and allow this
important development to proceed
thank you chairman thank you mr wood
spot on time there
right i believe catch the fielding has a
question
here's the feeling
have you or in your discussions with the
highways than others did you consider
putting a feed
feeder out from the site or bollards on
the
in the middle of the road stop people
turning in uh
going in the opposite direction and
basically crossing them the
the road
chairman the um council fielding we we
considered
several options in relation to access
and
restricted by the very large and
magnificent tree
to the site frontage and returned to
an arrangement that was similar to that
approved previously
in relation to the uh residential
development plan for the site
um the actual layout of the access has
been
designed with physical elements to it
which will mean that i will manage if
you like people's use of
it so that there will always be you know
that
these measures include an island which
will effectively
seek to manage people's movements from
the site to turn left out
and only be able to turn left in
so it is a fully detailed properly
managed
site entrance that we we put forward
this has been followed by highways
consultants
detailed background information and as
you can see
a lot objected to by either of the
highways authorities that have
considered it
thank you thank you okay catch the nails
thanks mr chairman oh good evening um i
wonder um
i have asked this question uh earlier
but was there any attempts
to have a consultation with the either
parish or town councils
on on this proposal and if not why not
councilor mills i i can advise that we
sent
an introductory letter and a full set of
submitted drawings to the parish council
as a consultation and
i never received any response
thank you very much lee thank you
all right any other questions
uh i've got one briefly uh mr wood
um you said you've got some uh
experience of other um
homes um any idea are you locally are
they in the midlands or um are they
other parts of the country
we our operational arm is ideal care
homes
um there are a number of care facilities
throughout the country a
sizable number in the midlands in
birmingham wolverhampton walsall
uh one currently being constructed in
dudley
um so we we've got a considerable
experience delight
of planning and development off so
exactly such facilities these are what
we specialize in
yep thank you very much at cancer cattle
thank you um
thank you for your presentation um
i was another question on the on the
parking issue and i know there was a
a question put forward by my colleague
councillor javier
before the meeting on this one um
but you're saying in your design access
statement
that there will be um at most 24 staff
on site
at any one point in time out of a total
of 50 or 60.
um but you've got 24 car parking spaces
um now
it's also suggested that residents might
have their own vehicles
um although i do know that you're
providing bicycle the provision for
bikes you know residents have access to
a bicycle park um
i'm i just really this is an area that
gives me most concern about this
i i think is is the lack of car park
spacing
um for 24 uh you know potentially 24
hours of staff
possibly residents as well visitors
whether they be staff
staff you know um
people helping or whether they be
genuine visitors to residents
um what happens when the car park is
full because you can't park on the road
outside that i that i will would you
like to sort of expand on on why you
think 24 is the adequate number
okay okay um sm
level of car parking that we proposed um
we have we have to go by the standards
applied
or adopted by the local authorities but
we we are also
in a position to draw on our own
experience
uh as a specialist developers of these
facilities
so this is the sort of level of car
parking that we would generally provide
in relation to this size of care
facility
and from our experience we've found that
this is
satisfactory in meeting the the general
demands
uh off off the operational care home on
a day-to-day basis
um there is a short period in any one
day when there are 24 staff on site
um but again we find there is more than
adequate car parking
for staff and we're not expecting staff
to arrive in individual vehicles
um we can mention that that we have
submitted a
travel plan with our application so
we'll be
making every effort to encourage car
sharing for instance which is
prevalent within our facilities but will
encourage the use of
other forms of uh travel if you like to
the care home
i did mention this is very much a
facility
in the current environment car sharing
is
is strictly strictly against uh the
suggestions
given the coroner's you know where we
are in the pandemic
uh and given this as a care home where
patients will be very very vulnerable to
any
continuation of pandemic the idea that
staff should be sharing coming in and
coming out
makes me feel even more uncomfortable
could you come back to me on on
how your suggestion of sharing works
with the medical guidance we have about
panda about car sharing and the pandemic
well not of course we're in unusual
circumstances at the moment
um but i'm not entirely sure that
car sharing is entirely ruled out
so long as that is done in a responsible
manner
um but what i the point the main point i
was getting to was that this is very
much a local facility so we're expecting
all of the sustainable modes of travel
to be available
to staff and visitors um
but i do understand why you're meeting
that and i'd probably believe that in a
short term
um that was an issue but car sharing
will be
something that will be seen as prevalent
within the uh
operation of the kill in the future
all right thank you nonetheless uh sorry
there was another point i think it was
mentioned um
you know we're we're dealing with the
care home you know residential care
for the elderly and generally uh
people need to occupy a care home so
i'm able to say that uh
100 of residents are unlikely to have a
car um
in fact we have very few instances in
fact almost no instances of residents of
any of our care facilities
still being a car owner and requiring
parking space so
the parking available is for staff and
visitors
and that's as a consequence of the
nature of the use
great thank you for that cancer fleming
right um a couple of questions one of
them i'm sorry labor's the parking
aspect a little bit
you say that uh there'll be 24 people on
site
on any one shift is that going to be
over a three shift system no they they
the arrangements in the home will be uh
two shifts
during the day which will be from eight
in the morning till eight in the evening
and the converse eight in the evening
through to eight in the morning
now that sounds fairly harsh but um
members of staff will also be working on
a four days on three days off basis
um so it tends to work and that's
that's seen to be the most efficient and
effective way
of staffing not only this
most care homes okay well the question
then is
if there are 24 people working on site
there's obviously going to be an overlap
system of those shifts so where do the
24 people are coming to work park
whilst the 24 people who are already
there
are parked in the parking spaces that's
that's the reason for asking the
question
about the shift overlap because you know
if you finish at eight in the evening
you don't clear off at eight o'clock
until you've done a full handover to the
people that are coming in
so you do have a situation where you're
going to have more than 24
cars on site potentially i know i know
there's a lot of arguments about
car sharing and some might have a car
some might have a bike
you still have a potential for many more
than 24 cars on site
so that that's my first point and the
second point is
have you got a demonstrable need for
this care home to exist in that area
because
we've already heard this evening that um
the other care homes within
three to four miles of this care home in
reddit are actually advertising for
residents because
they have capacity so that's why i just
want that that's a sort of a double
question really
what do you do at shift changeover what
do you do have you
decided on the need for this care home
to exist
okay the shift change over although the
um
general pattern is eighteen to eight
um it's not the case that everyone
leaves
at the same time there are a variety of
employment opportunities within the care
home some are domestic staff
summer carers others are managers
they all work to slightly different
times it would be the case that only
we would work to that shift pattern so
although there is a period of time
during any one day when there are 24
members of staff
they don't all arrive at the same time
and they don't all depart the site at
the same time
therefore besides car parks that we are
proposing
to again experience evaporation of the
other other
other care homes that we're responsible
for is sufficient to allow for
that staffing arrangement and that a
departure and arrival at the site
very adequately deals with it
so we don't find an issue with that and
of course we we don't worry we're
live in a situation here we don't find a
situation whereby
because of 24 members as fast as 24 cars
that
that just doesn't happen
okay and the second part of the question
lighting
um part of our um
analysis of the the name
yeah basis for progressing with this
application was that we believe there is
a dimensionable
demonstrable sorry demonstrable need for
the
proposed care home now we we have a
database ourselves that we check on this
and we believe that there is a strong
need
for for this type of care provision in
this location
and we've had that verified because we
involved
an independent specialist healthcare
consultant
that's used to doing these sorts of a
needs assessment
and that's to verify our own our own
database our own opinion
as well as to demonstrate to
to to yourselves as decision makers here
but they've also come up with a strong
demonstrable need
for the proposed facility i think
i think two different areas three miles
radius from the site
and as a check five miles we're
expecting people to
be resident within this care home to be
resident
or be dependent of people resident
within
three miles of this site and no more and
quite often
much less just add on props i don't know
follow up to that one
um obviously catch the
kettle touched on about car sharing out
of the pandemic
have have you noticed or any evidence
that
that people's opinions are changing
about
going into care homes in light of
concerns of the pandemic
and the outbreaks that we've had in care
homes throughout the country um
have you noticed any general reluctance
now has there been a change
or was that too early to say
um in in the the immediate
instance that there is a
concern but there is a concern for going
to a lot of places
um but what we're seeing is that people
are preferring
this type of accommodation whereby
we're offering single occupancy rooms
all with ensuite facilities
there's no sharing of uh facilities no
sharing of rooms
and what we're finding is that certain
care homes that
still share facilities are finding a
reluctance to people
moving in but we're finding if these
perk is built
uh residential care facilities
there is a is still a strong need to
still
still a strong demand and and no we're
not finding
that there's a an apparent reluctance
and as new care facilities are opening
um
we're finding that there is is
considerable demand okay
thank you catch the feeling did you
indicate you want to come back in
it's just a very quick one i'm horrified
to hear that you're expecting people
to come on bicycles and such a dangerous
part
so have you done any an analysis
on the amount of people who come by bike
or come by car
i think i think mr woody's i think he
wants more details of your transport
plan
yes i mean we what we do is we uh we
make provision
for cyclists as as you do as yourselves
as a local authority and i'm as i'm sure
red explorer
do to encourage people to cycle
and there will be cycle
storage or cycle parking if you like on
site um
for eight cycles so we're we're doing
our best to encourage people
to do this but i'm not sure about
horrified because
you know local authorities and ourselves
are making provisions for the
encouragement of cycling
uh all over their their administrative
areas
so um i'm not sure we'd be horrified
because i think
there are ways in which cycles can
safely
reach this site and then i would say
that this
cycling offers a very very much
an agreeable sustainable mode of travel
to the site as does
as does walking i'm just concerned
there's no cycle ways
or areas to for cyclists to get
uh directly along the roads that's what
concerns me
okay i think we've got that point
against the feeling i think
we we've had a real good uh debate uh
with the
agent um i think our proposed move on
um and uh i'll bring in our next speaker
which is
uh thank you mr wood and i'll bring our
next speaker mr hensha seraphin
councillor sorry there peter
that's fine thank you you'll appreciate
this one
because it will um be very short and
brief
now i support the last two counsellors
on their objections
and following on from my initial
objection
the national institute for health and
care
excellence nice has recommended
care homes should be protected from
pollution
and not built by main roads
we have two care homes in studly
at the present which are away from main
roads
we have one being built next to the
doctor's surgery
with a similar amount of beds
that's away from main roads so
i feel that we owe it to vulnerable
people
who need care better life conditions
and care homes should be built in lovely
areas
for their benefit so i urge the
committee members
to refuse this application because it's
not fit for purpose
on this site close to main roads with
such pollution
okay thank you
it was thank you sir very nice um any
questions for the ward member
let's have a quick conversation on
trying to multitask
uh count the males please
thank you chris uh hi uh
peter hello uh peter um
you mentioned the other care homes how
far
are they from this proposed care home
now what's the distance
um probably
two and a half mile two mile two and a
half miles so two and a half miles from
this okay that's all i need to know on
that one
okay thank you oh just one just sorry
just one other thing
um you you worried about the school
how close is the school to to this
care home yeah you wanted you wanted six
houses instead of
it's um approximately from the
roundabout
it's probably
150 yards or more okay
i think i think i'll give you a bit of
poetic license on that one councilor
mills um
we'll move on um any other questions for
the ward member cancer fielding
can't hear you again please catch the
building
that's no i was involved with the
planning for the gateway site
and there was a big discussion about
crossing the the dual carriageway
uh no it's not your carriageway there
but crossing that main road
for young children uh
is there is there still a problem there
with regards to children crossing the
road
and which side of the road is the school
i think it's on the off opposite side of
that road
cancer field and uh can you just
elucidate this more are you
the question is the question will the
increased
traffic coming from this site cause a
problem for local residents is that what
you're trying to do
for school children going from one side
to the other
i know but i'm just trying to see the
context of it counts there building
well it was a question that was raised
by
uh peter with regards to the school and
the neighborhood to the school
and also chris councillor kettle raised
it
um right then i think i'll try and
phrase that somehow um
um cancer hunter cerephon uh sorry about
this um
no no no problem i'm just trying to
phrase the question i'm concerned that
it
are you concerned that
the increased what effect do you think
uh the increased number of no i'm not
our financial really here
don't worry forget it uh yeah i think
it's i'm just concerned that
we're not asking a question that relates
to to this development
um because we've had
we've had the officers from the county
councils feedback on
on this application there will be a
transport management plan
um you could ask councillor hansel if in
about road safety in the area and where
how how many accidents
have been in the vicinity which which is
probably more pertinent so i'll probably
ask you that one
so question you know if there have been
any accidents in the vicinity
i don't have figures
as now for any accidents um
you could see how busy the road was
uh at a quiet time and i'd been sent
a picture at hapas4 when it was all
stationary and clogged
that's how busy it gets and it's only
going to get busier
when the amazon vans coming and going
i am concerned about older people
and we do owe it to them to provide them
with a lovely area where
they can away from pollution that's my
concern
okay yeah thanks to that yeah we did
obviously
several of us did go on a site visit uh
and we did
uh realized how quickly the traffic was
coming and
you know so and that's and that's for
riding a bicycle there
it would be well suicidal because i
don't see any bicycles going up and down
there it's too busy
too fast busy all right thanks for that
any further questions
um okay all right any further questions
no thank you cancer hunter sarafin
okay thank you we'll now move on to
points of clarification with officer
who wants to come in on that i'm sure
there's must be one or two questions
i've got a couple
um somebody's put speed but i'm not sure
who that is is that you count to the
mills
catch the mills then cancel the harvey
and then cancer fielding
thanks mr um can i ask uh
the uh the officer um
the the proximity i'm just a bit
concerned about the
the house that's there already is it
what is it is it mountfood what what was
the house called
the big house south south ashmount
ashmount oh got that wrong sorry
um can you tell me how close that is to
uh where the parking area is going to be
and also um there was a concern about
lighting
is this when people come in
uh at the night time is this could be
security lighting on on and off or is it
just
lighting there all the time so too quick
okay
okay so um regarding the proximity of
parking i've done
two measurements um from the system
uh so there it's it's approximately 15
meters from
the nearest point of the back of
ashmount to the parking area
and then the back of the rear boundary
so their their existing fence
is approximately eight meters but sorry
six meters to the
uh nearest park in bay that's the corner
of it so that's closest point to closest
point
okay and do you know about the lighting
with that's going
so yeah so the applicant has stated that
there will
be a need for for security lighting um
and i've um it's been proposed as a
condition that we could consider how
that's put in yeah
so yeah they're not proposing at this
moment in time 24-hour
permanent lighting and i think it would
be important for the character
that it wasn't as such but obviously
there's a balance between character and
security so
i think that's dealt with fire condition
yeah i say oh sorry for my
last no that's it that's the questions
for me no loud one you think come on
carry on counts to the mills
i was gonna say my concern is on this
um on lighting
um it's on all the time a bit of
pollution there
and they had security lighting going on
and off that's even more
you're saying you're not it's not going
to be on 24th
24 7 um but if it's security lighting
flashing on and off that that's a bit of
a disturbance isn't it for
for neighbors that sets my concern
that's all like as a concern not i'm not
expecting you to
sort it out thank you and you'll be
bringing that out in the divide
thank you yeah well thank you right i've
got
now councillor harvey thank you uh mr
chairman
i've got four prong question if that's
permissible of the officer
um or we can manage yeah far away
i will make them brief um could you
confirm that uh
questions of green belt are irrelevant
as far as this application is concerned
point one point two is built up area
boundary the vast majority of this site
is within the proposed built up area
boundary
i presume that the built-up area
boundary is not yet set in concrete and
therefore
it could encompass the the portion of
the site which is not
already within the built-up area
boundary i presume that's a possibility
the third point is my understanding is
that where
a developer comes along and says i want
to do x y and zed
the question of whether there is a
commercial need for that development
is a matter for him that's that's their
commercial risk to
to decide whether the need for the
particular product they want to offer
uh is there or not am i correct and my
final point
is i raised with you the question before
the meeting race we did the question of
the car parking uh in that's proposed in
this
instance compared with a home in
shipston which is relatively new
and you gave it what i thought was a
perfectly reasonable
um explanation of why i had
misunderstood or
they weren't totally comparable and
therefore you were satisfied that the
car parking space
that is provided in in this instance is
consistent with the level of car parking
proportionately
with the application that was approved
in ships that
am i correcting thinking that i'm sorry
to make it so complicated but i only
want to speak once
there's only three and a half questions
and that's very admirable
and so if other members could uh try and
do that i need to try and speak once it
make it easier as well for me
right the victoria um three and a half
questions i think there okay
so firstly turning to the um
green belt issue if i can try to share
my screen again
uh can you see this
are you able to see the screen yes thank
you
okay so um bear with me one moment
so uh on this screen here there's the
the darker green area let me just get
the laser pointer out
the darker green area here that's the
green belt designation
so it's opposite the site but no part of
the application site is within the green
belt
so on that basis greenbelt policy is not
relevant at all to the assessment of
this application
so that's the first question i believe
um the built-up area boundary
kind of excludes this little area here
and um it is a desk-based exercise when
it first
kind of goes into the um draft um
um plan so that the um site allocation
plan
it is draft at the moment and um
it is possible that that could be
included in the future
uh into the built-up area boundary um
commercial need um yes it is
um a risk for the for the developer
themselves
that they would consider whether there
is a need or there isn't a need
we as an authority haven't um any
specific data
on the need for care home facilities so
um
a needs assessment has been submitted as
part of this application and on the
basis of no other evidence um
we have to take that at face value when
we have no
evidence of our own to suggest that
there is a saturation of need
um and then uh finally yes
um in looking at the car parking for the
site this isn't an extra care
scheme so that means that we wouldn't be
expecting that any residents would have
their own parking facilities extra care
is that the type of
of use where perhaps um younger people
go into the facility
considering their their future need and
have a more independent side of living
and this is a c2 care home facility
where
we really would expect the parking to be
more for um
for staff and perhaps visitors and then
we have our own
parking standards which have been um
considered as part of the submission
thank you for that sir victoria i've
never got cancer the feeling
john we still can't hear you
part of the ques my question was what
ross said that i should ask the officer
about the green belt
which i think um councillor harvey's
already referred to
because that was raised by one of the
councillors
about the the this site um
to which i think the answer was it's
green field not green belt
the other thing was that we now insist
on electrical charging points
um in houses that we we give planning to
are there going to be enough electrical
charging points in the future if there's
only two
two positions
uh so yeah i believe that two are
proposed and that's in
accordance with what would be required
under the
um uh i think it's the parking stand as
part of the development requirements spd
it might also be within the um air
quality and or the
um
climate change sections as well but
certainly within the development
requirements spd
thank you thank you catch the cattle
thank you mr chairman um right um i'm
i'm going to try and do a
councillor harvey and wrap it all up in
one spiel which hopefully will keep you
happier
um firstly um
is the pavement access into the site
uh from the bridge end
which is after all the bigger area of um
where was more staff i like to come um
secondly uh the existing barns are quite
high
what is the is there a significant
difference in height between this
the proposed building and the barns
um is there any landscaping proposed
between
um the property that council mills was
referring to and i'm afraid
my mind's called blank of what it's
called um and the
the site to to give them some sheltered
their own amenity
from this quite considerable building is
going to go up
um councillor hendricks therapy talked
about air quality
um and made that uh that was uh that was
effectively his sole
um his major contribution to
to tonight's debate um
could you comment on air quality uh and
what
what with that does have any relevance
to this application
and finally car parking standards um
i've actually got on my screens and
sadly you won't have it well you may
have it
but nursing our own car parking standard
for non-resident staff requires
one space per two staff for visitors one
spaced
per five units now if i add
those two together that comes to
25 and then there is a question of
whether there is a warden
uh or wardens who might need their own
car parking facilities
on top um
so if i just add up non-resident staff
and visit
that comes to 25. um
that is our own standard now when our
spd was produced that was before
um the ugly kovid raised its head
and car sharing is not something that
we're being encouraged to do
so i'm wondering whether in fact our spd
on car stat on car parking standards
um represents the absolute minimum
and if we go for the absolute minimum
number of cars then car parking isn't
adequate
um i go back to question of whether
people come in by bicycle or pavement
um doesn't appear to be a pavement but
you might correct me
and and there's council fielding that
said there doesn't appear to be any
cycle ways into this site i'll stop
talking now you might be pleased here mr
chairman
thanks for that i know that
um i think that um
the current spd uh standards
uh what would still apply yes they may
have to be
uh amended in light of the pandemic um
but i'm sure
our legal officer ross will go to
confirm that there's no changes at the
moment in light of
uh in light of that covert 19 is that is
that right ross
the changes to the um to the policy
chairman
oh only part of that could just come
back in
i'm not aware of any changes that have
been made or proposed to be made to
the policy i don't know if planning
manager is aware of anything but i'm not
yeah can i just come back
hold on a second chris let me um alice
come in please
thank you chairman yeah just to confirm
there's been no changes to the spd as a
result of the chronovirus pandemic as
as far as i'm aware no draft changes or
suggestions at this current point in
time
right victoria far away now
okay uh so the first part was um in
relation to pavement access into the
site
there is a pavement along the warwick
highway um i think
um those that visited the site today
walked along it with me
um so certainly from the ashmount house
and up to the
the roundabout there's a pavement and in
fact there's one on the other side of
the road as well
in part but certainly on on the side
where the um
the care home is proposed there is a
pavement um
with regards to the height of the barns
and the height of the property
um i have to say i don't know what the
existing height of the barns is
um i would estimate it's quite similar
um
it's a a nine nine meter at its highest
i believe the proposed uh elevations
um although i'd need to double check my
report to
to remember that off the top of my head
but i think it is comparable to a
two-story house and there is a slight
decrease in land level height um from
the pavement into the site
uh which um can to some extent help to
accommodate the height uh landscaping
let's see if i can um pull up the
drawings again
is that sharing okay
victoria yes okay thank you
right so this is the ashmount house
here okay let me just find the little
laser
uh so that's the the house there there
are two protected trees on the boundary
to the rear there which would be um
retained
and they are between obviously the rear
of the property and the
the car parking here and then there
would be
landscaping in general around the
property
uh there is a condition proposed for
landscaping so
um if if there was any particular
requirement for additional
landscaping that could be worded into
the condition if we felt that were
appropriate
um moving on to air quality
an air quality assessment was submitted
with the application
this is considered to be a medium scale
property in air quality terms
as part of the development requirements
spd
and the relevant provisions have been
put in place for that
um to mitigate for air quality this
isn't an
air quality a high air quality area so
certainly environmental health have been
consulted on this application and they
have raised no particular concerns
um for the welfare of residents as a
result of air quality nor have they
required any
additional um measures to be put in
place
for that level of protection so as far
as i'm aware there is no specific impact
that
that any of our expert consultants would
have raised in that manner
um and car parking standards i think um
you're correct it would be 25 overall
um so it is one short of the guidance um
i think it's guidance as opposed to a
standard in
in terms of its wording in the
development requirements spd
um so yeah this is one short of that
there hasn't as far as i'm
aware being any update or consideration
as to how we would deal with this
uh kind of use in relation to the covid
pandemic and it will be
quite new to all of us um
i don't think there's anything that
anything else i can add on that
particular matter
right thank you for that can i just come
back on on that
one briefly yeah firstly i have just
checked on google earth
and there is a pavement goes admittedly
from the entrance to this property to
ash something house but i was correct
unless there has been a change since i
visited the site
uh there is no there is no purely a
verge between
ash whatever it is house on the road
going due west to the roundabout
there is no there is no there is no
pavement
on either side of the road beyond ash
was ashburn house
i think could you confirm that
um victoria if you bear with me i can
ask councillor hancher seraphin as the
ward member who knows the area
um it's probably assuming he knows it
much better than you if you were happy
for him to answer that one yeah
more than happy with that yes yes okay
chairman um there isn't a full pavement
all the way from down the waraka way it
only goes to ashmount
on either side it doesn't extend
any further down at all thank you
thank you thank you victoria right i
think we've
no further questions um i think we need
to move on to
the divide i don't think we've missed
anybody else i think we've
been going on this one a good while and
lots of very important questions
right cancel the mills
yes thanks ms jen well we've heard um
quite a bit about not having pavements
going to it um
uh lack of car parking spaces i'm not
con
convinced about that um
and being in an appropriate place i mean
it's it's a very very
busy uh section of the
road there very very busy i'm not sure
that it is the right place for
care home but um i'm not too sure about
someone at the moment
mr chairman at the beginning i think
yeah we need you know
care home people living longer um
and then inevitably a lot of people have
to go in care homes but
uh it does seem a little bit
unsustainable so uh
i'll wait to hear what everybody else to
say mr chairman before i make a decision
thank you very much thank you cancer
mills i've got cancer cattle and
councillor harvey
sorry yeah thank you mr chairman
um i can see
the um the need the need for care homes
uh as councilman mills is referred to um
we are all getting older by the minute
um that the population is getting older
and therefore the provision of care
homes of this nature to to the elderly
is something that we we should be
considering um
i've taken into account the ward members
concerns about air pollution
um and whilst i completely unsung where
he's coming from
um if we're told that environmental
health have tested this
and are comfortable with the level of
air pollutant on this site then
that gives me i'm not going to say a lot
of comfort but some comfort
um maybe things will improve as people
go to more electric cars and
then the amount of internal combustion
pollution will reduce
but it is a very very busy crossroads
which leads to
my third point um
as as the board member has confirmed
there is no pavement from central
redditch into this cycle on the white
road on either side
although there is immediately adjacent
to the the site
um people are not going to be safe
walking along a verge
to get into this site to coming from
work and actually redditch is a big area
um and there's an awful lot of traffic
in there i i'm concerned
that people will not be walking the site
also as i mentioned earlier on worked
around here for quite some
time and the amount of traffic on the
road
is very considerable um
and bicycling without any cycle lane or
any protection for cyclists
is again an area which i just do not
think will happen on this site
um it is you know it's not in in the
rural area but it is remote from
the central built-up area of both maple
maple green
and um and redditch so we go back to
cars
now if we look at the spd um
what it says is the parking standard
should be taken as a starting point
and each proposed scheme should be
assessed accordingly
this is this is not domestic housing
where we say
x number of units per bedroom um
for a resident or in a private
residential house this is a very
different situation
um and because it's not a standard and
it's
guidance the fact that we haven't
produced a new standard
to um reflect covered
pandemic whatever else you want to call
it does not mean
because we haven't produced a standard
this guidance
um is is is is still
completely valid because it as it says
at the bottom of table one residential
development
parking standards nursing homes or
similar
these are guidance
and when we we do the sums and we find
we're one
short anyway based purely on
non-resident staff and visitors
and we haven't got a space for a warden
um
and we're not going to be able to admire
your bicycle here or walk here
um i'm i'm concerned um and i've read
the response to councillor harvey's
question
which he submitted earlier that this is
different to the
ships inside but i'm talking about the
practicalities of getting into this site
whichever way you come whether you're
coming um
south down the birmingham road east
along the road
west along the warwick road you've still
got to get inside the site
and i think this is um this is
vulnerable to lack parking
and i have a real concern that
where we are now we do not need a new
spd
because the current one says it is a
guidance
and the guidance we must use our
judgment and our judgment
is we're in a different world today than
we were
when the guidance was originally issued
and that suggests
car parking stands at a minimum aren't
even met
and because where we are now and there
won't be any car sharing
i think we have a problem with car
parking on this site
um yeah thanks for watching i would
just say it's you know we could say that
about any potential
pandemic or or change that something
that we approve now the standards that
we have now
might not be suitable within 12 months
or or two years time because of
something else and i'm very i'm very
concerned about
preempting any potential change the spd
and i'm you know i'm again i think i
might have to
call on ross um to you know
whether whether it is totally out of uh
out of bounds on this
i'm really concerned that preempting
and i know that we've had this issue and
in my ward recently
there was one with no spaces and there
should have been four
i know that with 24 out of 25 in my
mass that's 96 percent of um
provision so 90 if i got 96 percent of
my a-levels i would have um
i might have been okay um and then
but we weren't mentioning levels will we
um so yeah i'm very
you know i think i've got concerns about
getting there
i've got concerns when i was on site
today
the speed of the traffic uh and its
location
but as for
um for changing the policy on parking
in light of covid uh things if this was
approved and built it might take two
three years to do
uh things might be totally different so
again it's very difficult to preempt
or foresee what's going to happen in two
or three years time because i
i'm sure in 2015 when somebody says well
where will you be in two in five years
time nobody could ever predict what's
happened in the last six months
and i'm not trying to make light of that
situation it's things
are so unpredictable so that's all i'll
have to say
and i'll bring cancer harvey in against
the harvey
can't hear you trevor yeah yeah thank
you very much
um for me there are there are two
fundamentals uh to this application one
is that it's put forward by
um a developer who has long experience
in designing and operating
this sort of facility they have it
at their disposal at the moment at this
stage to design
something and put it forward which
either causes them problems they can't
deal with
or doesn't cause them problems and they
can operate it successfully
their view clearly is that what they
have proposed works for them
and they've got long long experience on
which to draw to come to that conclusion
the second point is we have an officer
and a team of officers
who have looked at this application from
all sorts of directions
and particularly the the highways
question of access and so on has been
poured over by
highway experts and the uh
the information which has come back is
they have no objection
now we might have concerns about uh
footpaths and cyclists and so on but i'd
urge councillors to take the bigger
picture
and the bigger picture is that here we
have an application
from a responsible proven operator
which is supported by our professional
staff
as far as i'm concerned i would approve
this application
and if you need a proposal to that
effect i'm happy to be that proposer
thank you cancer harvey i'll put that to
one side for the moment
and then i'll bring in cancer fielding
okay um looking at the site in the car
parking area
there doesn't seem to be a proper
service
allowance for the building for bringing
in the goods and services
it's one of these sites it's a scheme
that i'm
completely neutral on i'm very much in
line with
councillor mills on this one i
don't like the highway issue um
and if there was the the sap area
further up the road
which they're talking about putting some
houses on we'll get that's going to be
another problem with junctions and
everything else
um i can't make my mind up at the moment
which is probably a rarity but
um i will leave it to other people
to come forward with ideas
right so i think everybody knows
spoken on this we've got a proposal to
grant this application from councillor
harvey
i'll be a seconder for that proposal
um i think that i think i
will second this that i have got
reservations about this
um um but i think i will to move this on
to secondly proposal to
grant this application
uh i think we need to go to the vote
then
no i've got a comment uh
well we've heard of repairs on a
secondary um is there a point of order
cancer cattle
uh it's to do with a a condition on
landscaping
which i seem to remember at the previous
meeting
uh where the conditions were determined
beforehand
uh mr nash was concerned about um
that uh ross may take a different role
sorry mr chambers may take a
different view um but it would seem that
uh if you are proposing
to support this application uh we should
consider conditions
and one con one can one condition i
would like to see
is some sort of screening given the
security lighting issues that's been
raised earlier on some sort of
vegetative screening between
um the house ash
ashmore house i'm looking for somebody
to nod but
victoria's looking very ashmore has
thank you
some sort of screening uh at the back
end of the premises
to give them some enhanced um protection
against the
the level of the volume of lighting
that's going to be required to keep
this facility safely appropriate
appropriately saved
german are you happy for me to put
something there
yes victoria okay so the obviously the
landscaping condition is for
discharge would be discharged in the
future and i think it would be
appropriate to add a note
um stating what we would expect to be
submitted within that landscaping
um submission that would then inform
um how that could be discharge of what
might be considered acceptable
so we could absolutely make a note to
suggest uh
that there should be screening to the
rear of that property included within
the
landscaping submission the second
condition
the second condition i've been may not
be possible
um but given the fact that there is not
a pavement that goes down towards the
next roundabout on the warrick road
going
west towards redditch uh could we
request that a contribution is made
to ensure that there is a pavement that
goes uh that
that means foot access from the west
can be achieved without working walking
on a on a grass verge
okay ross is that a uh a reasonable
condition
or is that um especially
it's
i think it would be tricky because we
don't have any indication of
how much that contribution should be for
and we don't have any indication from
highways as to whether such a scheme is
something they could do
so i think it would be difficult to
justify
that thank you for that and on this and
another ac
is just indicated yeah
just to reiterate exactly what ross has
said um i would
suggest that we don't attach or seek to
secure any such contribution in absence
of that request coming from county
highways
for the exact reasons that ross has just
uh just relayed
okay okay let's let's move this on now
then
um we've had a proposal to grant the
application
um olivia we go to do the vote for us
please
i can yes can i just confirm that um you
and councillor harvey um are happy with
the note that's going to be added
yes yes that's fine yeah
councillor building
uh abstain
councillor fleming abstain
councillor harvey four and cancer kettle
uh a counselor kettle against
chair that's three four one against and
two abstentions
right uh committee resolves to grant
application
uh twenty slash zero zero five two
one slash full uh with uh
the notes and conditions that we've also
just added on as well
uh and in the update sheet as well um
those ones there was one in there as i
wasn't there as well
um right thank you for that we'll now
move on to
our next and final item on the agenda uh
do we need to have a small break to call
in the um
yes have a little drive
just to get the speakers in right
i need everybody back by five passes
2001 so if you could be back by 2005
again you've been sat down for a while
and if you could mute your microphones
please
thank you
thanks to this
all right let's make sure everybody's
back in the room
i think i am right
it's everybody there
catch the mills are you there
the chairman are you here casper mills
yeah yes i am i am
good i can see catch the field in cancer
harvey
all right catch the fleming are you with
us
oh yeah i can see you and that's the
hunter's elephant i think we're all here
now
right we will move on to the last item
on the agenda which is twenty slash
zero zero nine seven eight slash full
rockstone farm
admin turn ships and monstera
i farm i'm just running and
our presented officer is mr paul
thompson paul
far away when you're ready please
thank you chair good evening members and
honored guests
um let me just get this up
uh we'll see that
yeah brilliant yep
okay so as the sheriff said we are at
larkstoke
farm which is just on the outskirts of
the cotswolds aonb which is just to the
south of the road there
the site is the black dot um
this is the proposed site plan um
we're looking at this evening is a new
dwelling
for an assistant farm manager for
lockstep farm itself which is a
medium scale grain
farming and processing facility there is
already
a dwelling on site over here which is
the main farmhouse
and there is a dwelling opposite other
than that it's it's a fairly isolated
site
this is the
is a bit of a closer view of that and
just shows that the
we're going to have um the new new
dwelling um
to the to the left essentially as you
look at it from the road
and it's going to be fairly well
screened and proposed to be fairly well
screened with
trees and new planting uh at the moment
however i'm sorry this is these are the
elevation proposed elevations it's a
a low single story log cabin style
um structure um
as i was saying that there is a lot of
new planting proposed this is the
current
view and fairly open uh across the
fields
to the north um viewed from that
direction it will be
viewed against these larger um
agricultural buildings
um which form the main parts of the site
chair the recommendation is to refuse
this um new dwelling on the grounds that
um an essential need for it has not been
established
um and that would then create an
isolated dwelling in the countryside
thank you thank you paul we'll now move
on to our
first speaker which i believe should be
catch the sue cook chair of abington
parish council catch the [ __ ] can you
hear us please
catch the [ __ ]
press star six to a mute
hello hello is that cancel the cook
yes it is good evening we can hear you
you've got three minutes cancel the cook
we will give you a warning with 30
seconds to go
and please stay with us after you finish
speaking as there may be questions for
you from
members of the committee far away when
you're ready please
thank you edmonton parish council
supports planning application
20 stroke double o 978 stroke fall
for a farm manager's dwelling at
larkstoke farm
badminton the council considers that the
application meets the criteria for the
creation of a new dwelling
in a rural area as it is satisfied that
there is an essential need
for the assistant manager to live
permanently at
or near his place of work following
discussions with the applicant
the council appreciates the necessity
for the farm manager
to live on the premises there is a
functional need
established for a manager to live
permanently at
or near the place of work in this
instance the manager
needs to be on site 24 hours a day
to help run the business efficiently and
safely
to protect from crime and to deal with
to deal quickly with emergencies
that could cause serious loss of crops
rain storage and drying can be very
dangerous which means that is essential
to have a manager on site
to supervise the process and deal with
any problems
during the height of the season the
unloading and loading of grain
can take place until late at night so a
full-time employee is vital
we note that mr fox suggests buying a
house in the area
but the employer wants the manager to
live on site to manage the grange
store and share responsibilities with
himself
the applicant requires an employee of a
certain caliber
and would need to be able to offer
housing on sites to attain such an
employee
who would undoubtedly have a family
which he or she would want
close by we do not support new housing
lightly in our village
but in this case we support the
application
we were pleased to note that the
applicant has agreed to our request for
additional planting of trees and hedges
in order to screen the building as much
as possible from the road
banks will request that if permission is
granted for this application
a condition is attached to ensure the
property is occupied
solely by an agricultural worker
employed by lark soap farm
thank you thank you councillor cook i
believe
councillor kettle has a question for you
council kettle
good evening councilman cook um
there is already a a farm house there
and i
as you you will appreciate because you
and i know each other
um there is a
the farm has expanded uh and it is you
know
quite significant um operation
uh in fact i would say unlike um mr
thompson this is a pretty large farming
enterprise
um but there is already a
a farmhouse which is occupied by the
farmer
on the site and whilst it
they may not have immediate visibility
all the way around
he is there isn't he
yep he is there but i think he wants
he wants to be able to have a family
life as much as anybody else
and and wants to share the
responsibility with a manager now
and that's the reason he wants another
dwelling there
okay all right
that's the harvey would like to come in
please
uh yes if i can
yes um counselor
uh we're in a bit of a cleft stick here
uh
we have uh a report from
a an agricultural consultant who is
professionally qualified
and experienced his report has been
accepted by the officers as the basis
for the recommendation to refuse
could you outline your standing
uh to give your opinion on this
particular specific matter
[Music]
well as i've said we we know that they
have got a big
um grain storage and drying operation
there
um and i think if i'm right mr fox in
his report
uh talks more about the need for another
dwelling if there was animals involved
but the grain storage and drying is an
important thing
and you know you do need extra help
especially at this time of year
and i can't comment entirely on mr fox's
thing i have read it that's
what is in front of me i'm afraid um but
we fell from paris council from what we
know locally
that uh mr wilson certainly needed
support there
so just to clarify you're not claiming
that you
represent a parish council or yourself
as somebody having specific professional
knowledge
of this particular requirement under the
uh the national planning policy
framework
is that correct
i'm not claiming to be an expert like mr
fox no
i'm planning to have local knowledge and
as a parish council
it was something we agreed that we felt
would be right for that business to be
able to continue
um and and let mr wilson himself have a
life as well
yep thank you thank you very much catch
the [ __ ] any
other questions
i can't see anybody indicating
thank you councillor [ __ ] you're you're
free to go but stay stay with us to uh
listen to the debate right thank you
very much thank you
thank you bye right our next speaker
which is
mr james wilding um mr wilding are you
with us and have i
pronounced your surname correctly
the chairman is here
thank you
mr warding are you with us
mr warren
um mr chairman you might not have heard
of liz's liz's instructions
christ gesture repeats it because
mr wilding star six
mr did you get that can you press star
six
to unmute because we can't hear you at
the moment
so
i'm gonna remember meeting chairman and
try and call him in a different way so
just bear with me for
one minute
okay
can you press star six to a meet please
we can mr wilding is that you
hello yes absolutely sorry right
and we we've got you now you're quite
faint so um
if you can speak up as much as you can
and we'll speak up yeah that's fine
you've got three minutes and we'll give
you a warning
thank you can i make a start now
yes you can yeah far away then
mr wilding three minutes with 30 seconds
warning
thank you the applicants require
accommodation for a farm manager
to ensure that the grain storage and the
11 000 plus tons of crops stored within
the facility
are maintained in optimum commission
condition various crops need different
conditions depending on humidity
and wind speed the system needs to be
monitored every few hours
and adjusted to respond to the condition
of the crops particularly during the
summer and autumn
while some of this work is automated
moist seed or mechanical failure
can lead to deterioration in the quality
of the crop
within a matter of hours failure to deal
with such problems probably can result
in the entire crop
being written off or rendered unsuitable
for human consumption
the efficient running of the grain store
is a skilled operation and is crucial to
the success of the farm
the provision of a security guard let
alone other farm staff
would not have the necessary skills to
manage the grain store
and that significant damage may arise
before they detect problem
this is not a nine-to-five activity
hourable farming and associated work
involved
often needs to be carried out at
anti-social hours and a number of
operations are dependent on the weather
taking account of the considerable size
of the holding 3
600 acres compared to the average uk
farm size
of 213 acres and the need to monitor the
operation of the grain store
it is my opinion that on-site presence
during the day
and night would enable the fire manager
to deal quickly with situations that
could otherwise
cause serious loss of crops or products
except for the existing farmhouse
occupied by the applicants
there are no dwellings on the
application site or any other buildings
capable of conversion to a dwelling
this is a diversified farming business
and part of the portfolio includes a
number of properties
owned either by the business or solely
in the name of the applicant
none of these properties are suitable in
terms of their location
and available and therefore have been
disregarded
the council's advisor highlights the
availability of property
three miles away from the site for which
i have to dismiss
these as being unsuitable given
principally their distance from a
functional need
the functional test we undertake is
necessary to establish whether it is
essential
for the proper functioning of the
enterprise for one or more workers to be
readily available at most times it is my
opinion that for the key worker to be
readily available to satisfy the
functional need
the dwelling should be cited on the
holding and within close proximity of
the key functional buildings
enable this essentially to be
satisfactorily discharged
whilst this is not a succession case
this is about the progression of the
farming business
and the benefit for future generations
the wilson family have farmed the
holding for more many many years
with the applicant being the third
generation
as a professional advisor advising
private clients
and local authorities for nearly 25
years
i am very aware the need for local
authorities to scrutinize these
applications carefully
given their nature and countryside
location in this case in my opinion
there is justification
and i support the need for a further
dwelling on the soft to meet the growth
but a difference of opinion between
professionals in line with vocal support
i respectfully request that the
committee approved the proposal
thank you very much thank you uh
to give you a little bit of leeway
because of the problems we had with the
line
yeah no not a problem um catch the field
feeling you've got a question
for mr warding
a couple of questions if i may uh i'll
put them together as such
the house on the opposite side of the
road i gather doesn't belong to mr
wilde mr wilson um
and uh what sort of acreage
does mr wilson farm that needs those
large amount of buildings
the total holding is 3 600 acres
and that is the main site of the farm
buildings
and yours on the opposite side of the
road
sorry say that again a house on the
opposite side of the road
that does not belong to the to the um uh
applicant now
thank you right cancer cattle
um yeah cancer cattle yeah thank you
um mr world um
we heard from the chairman of the parish
council
um that uh mr wilson
wants to have a bit of a break um
and i speak as a former combine
harvested operator
so i understand all thought about grain
and grain storage
during the harvest time anybody involved
in the industry
realizes at that stage it's all hands to
pump
um and that you don't take your holiday
when you're combining
um once the crop has
um you've got the moisture down to the
appropriate
level then it is relatively stable and
you may get changes due to
infestation by by um
[Music]
one of the bugs or whatever um as a
subsequent stage but there is not an
urgent crisis that needs to be dealt
with at three o'clock in the morning
um so it seems to me whilst i completely
understand one needs to have people
present on site
if you are the farmer you will be on the
site anyway
um and therefore the need to have a
second
expert on site during that critical
harvest time is superfluous is it not
uh
the crops are being stored on site for
um you know for anything that's nearly a
year you know that
the last crop will go out uh of the site
um
in in june the following year just
before the next harvest continues
and during that time the crop is not
stable as you would say
it needs to be regularly turned the
temperatures can fluctuate
dramatically and there is always a fire
risk that could
could happen at any time
right thank you for that any further
questions
okay um against the field and just
briefly then you've had
you've already had two um we are trying
to
trying to move on
can't hear you john
i'm just looking at the comments made by
mr fox the african claims that given the
scale of the enterprise
his duties call him away from the site
frequently
does that is does mr wilson work
elsewhere
or is he a businessman in in
in other capacity
[Music]
this is a a diversified farm um
like many uh he does run a concrete
business from the site
uh as well as the the farming business
uh
the the 3600 acres that he does farm
he's not all ring fenced in one in one
location as well so
so you know he's being pulled um across
the area
to to deal with matters and you know a
simple example the other day was one of
one of the staff that
managed to um crash one of one of their
combines
um uh quite late at night i understand
um
and of course he was taken off the
holding um so that's
so that's an example where you know
where he is he's taken away
and obviously being being an arable
business okay it's not livestock
um but you know all of the all of the
demands of the
of the craft are both on site and
offside
um
this is uh you know it's a 24-hour
business and it's 365 days a year
and to expect somebody to be working you
know full
full day over that period seems
unreasonable
okay thank you for that thank you it
wasn't council the kettle drive in that
combine harvested by any chance was it
um no right thank you very much uh
you're free to go
uh before we go into points thank you
before we go into points of
qualification um
there was mention in cancer kettle and i
don't know where you've seen the chat
um that you knew councillor
cook um papyrus counsellor
um i assume that this will
uh there's no declaration of interest on
this that you have to declare
um it won't make any impact on your
decision on this one
do you come back in and confirm
something please very happy to come back
on that
um i as you know i've lived and farmed
in warwickshire for
um well i've lived here 60 years and i
know an awful lot of people live in the
countryside
i have to know councillor cook not as a
great friend
um but uh as an acquaintance and
her involvement in this decision has no
impact on my ability to um uh
consider this application right
thank you i just needed to confirm that
right catch the mills
uh you want to come in on the debate and
application
or declaration of interest really mr
chairman i'm just thinking
if it's the same suit cook then i do
know sue cook from old so um
um it can't be two sue cooks that i know
um so i've declared an interest but it
hasn't clouded my judgment mr chairman
brent so you're willing to stay and
debate with an open mind absolutely
brilliant thank you for that ross
hopefully we'll we'll
clear that up and we can move on right
we'll now move on to points of
clarification
for the officer uh
and my
right cancer fielding points of
clarification by the way
and we can't hear you know the
the report done by the uh consultant
i presume that he was fully aware of the
size of the
enterprise that was involved and
therefore should have taken into account
a very large farm which
takes a lot of management is that the
case
paul yeah okay to answer that one yeah
that's that's correct
council fielding the the um mr fox was
presented with the application documents
um the justification that mr wilding
produced
was available to him
thank you any other points of
clarification with officer
i can't see anybody at the moment
no anybody else there i know my screen
is playing up i've only got i can only
see paul at the moment
so uh nothing cancels the field input
yeah i can't see anybody else
or anything through the chat at cancer
kettle
you just caught me in time
thank you um mr thompson
what is an essential need
um because clearly the
the applicant's agent believes in the
central need that we have
that we have addressed as a council is
different to his assessment
do you want us do you want to help us
with that um
where you see and i said what how you
define an essential need
yes counselor um i did set this out in
in my report so this is what the um
and you'll forgive me for looking away
i'm actually reading another screen
um the mppf or other
the the ppg the planning practice
guidance sets out
what we should take into account when
we're looking at an essential need
and includes um factors such as
um whether first of all
the obvious whether it is actually
necessary for them
to be there to to oversee the process
viability which
we've we've covered elsewhere this is
this is clearly a viable business that's
not something that
we need to be concerned about um
this isn't a new enterprise either it's
been going for a long time so
another factor that the ppg refers to is
is whether we could put a caravan on
site for example
whilst whilst it finds its feet again
that doesn't apply
the two remaining factors basically that
we have to look at
within the five that the ppg sets out
are
that that essential need in other words
whether
whether the agriculture operation
literally cannot continue without
um this worker being present
and the second factor is whether there
is another way of meeting
that need if it is essential in other
words whether
um a couple of the proposals i put
forward in the
um report were a security guard for
example or
or additional equipment things like that
that's not to say that they would work
in this instance just
those are examples of ways in which a
proposal might fail to meet that need
if that makes sense
right thank you for that let's see who
else we've got
uh right then catch the fielding
from the coming john are you with us
my mutant myself don't seem to go
together very well
um under as10 residential
um e a dwelling that forms
part of the conservation
of a building in open countryside where
is ancillary to a business and is
necessary
to secure the efficient and security
operation
of the business tim
bearing in mind at the present moment
there's a lot of thefts going on in the
countryside
um the the need for security is a very
important part of it it's all very well
the farmhouse being on one side of the
buildings
but i can see the balance required for
a new property is this has that been
taken into account
in the uh mr fox's comments
i think i'm not sure he didn't get the
broadband very well but i think paul did
say
that mr fox did touch on about security
guards as well
uh um i think he said it wouldn't i
heard that but security guards
having run a security business to get
security guards to sit all night
um outside a set of buildings is a very
expensive way of dealing with it
but yeah i won't say um i think we've
got to just
we're going to point to them the debate
in a minute um paul
you can answer that if you want um i i i
think
as you say i covered covered what
mr fox has had access to in my previous
answer but
one thing i would just add um
it's completely slipped my mind now i
come to think of it um
yeah no i don't think it was anything
particularly particularly important
apologies yep no problems
right any other alice
you want to come in with some
clarification yes i'm happy for you to
come in
thank you chairman i think i just wanted
to clarify the point of as10 which
councillor fielding is referring to
as10e
relates to the conversion of an existing
building so it's not relevant in this
case this is a new building entirely so
that's why paul has correctly assessed
the application uh under as10
um i which is relates to
rural workers sweating so i just wanted
to clarify that for members
great thank you for that i can't see
anybody
else indicating to clarify anything
with the officers so we'll move on
we'll go on to the debate who wants to
come in on the debate
bearing in mind i can't see many people
count to the mills
can you come in then please yeah uh
yes thank thank you mr chairman um
yes i uh diligently went along and
looked at this uh
application uh but i mean
paul thompson has made a good report
there um
robert fox has made an extremely good um
report and for my mind
i reading this report and um
pull something up i sure think we should
support the officer's recommendation mr
chairman
thank you thank you council mills right
cancel the fielding catch the kettle and
cancel the harvey
i'm afraid i've got to take the opposite
view because quite honestly
the security of these types of building
with the modern
um ability of people
removing objects that they feel they can
sell in the open market is is very high
at the moment
um there is also vandalism
uh this day and age people the vandals
have got
cars they can come out it is important
that the
property is well secured and guarded
and i will i go i'm not prepared to
support the offices on this i would
actually go
for granting okay
i've got cancer the kettle then cancel
the harvey
against the cattle can you come in
please yeah i think
thank you mr chairman i think this is
this is a difficult one
um because 3600 acres
is a very very significant
arab operation and this site is on
[Music]
the edge of the road um it doesn't
benefit from a long drive
which many enterprises do have which
having said
that don't seem to make securing
farm businesses any more secure whether
at the end of a short or a long drive
um it's this essential need issue
which i think where i i'm strung up on
this and i don't
i'm not quite sure which way i'm going
to go
um i completely accept
um that there is need for 24-hour
supervision during harvest time um
and other peak periods um
but there are many many businesses where
there are fire risks
um where the entire
factory or farm can be destroyed by
a car going off but actually every
modern farmer as every modern business
does have
heat sensors smoke sensors etc etc
which will give adequate warning
of those sort of problems
this is a difficult area to secure
because it is
accessed right throat and it is quite
possible
for people to come in as they do but the
machinery stores i noticed at the back
of the buildings
quite close to farmhouse um and
therefore
one will consume with security lighting
and everything else
um and somebody living in the main
farmhouse
you have got somebody there present all
the time
um having said that you know when you
have got
um 3 000 acres worth of grain
um 14 000 tons uh you want to keep it in
very very good condition
um but that is that is part of the
farming operation
um having said that the property itself
um unlike the application that we didn't
look at this morning
or this evening um the property is
um you know designed uh to fit into the
farm
[Music]
landscape uh it's not a grandstanding
property it's utilitarian
um i would say actually very utilitarian
so i think you know
there isn't a risk here that someone is
going to build it and block it off as a
nice country house
um so i'm finding this quite a difficult
one i think paul has assessed it
absolutely appropriate within terms of
our policies
um he's given a very clear report um
it is just this dichotomy i have between
um what is a very large enterprise and
whether it's appropriate to have one
build
one domestic residents looking after it
as opposed to two
thank you right we'll
move on to councillor harvey then
councillor fleming
thank you mr chairman um i don't have a
problem with this
case we are told that the one and only
uh question we have to answer is does
this
application satisfy the essential test
that's required we've had a report from
an experienced
agricultural consultant who
has all had all the information that
councillor kettle referred to he knows
how
difficult and or or otherwise an
operation of this size is he knows how
big the farm was
he knows what the what the difficulties
are with grain storage
and uh he has made a report his report
is very clear if he had said
if he had concluded on the balance of uh
arguments i come to this conclusion
rather than that conclusion
uh i would be perhaps more unsettled
but i'm not because mr fox
did not come to an unequivocal sorry an
equivocal
answer he came to a very unequivocal
answer and that was
that this uh the test of
essential need for a dwelling on this
site
in on this particular farm is not
met and on that basis i've heard nothing
other than i've had nothing really
that that would persuade me that uh i
that
mr fox's uh report deserves to be
undermined
and therefore i'm quite happy to accept
the recommendation
that uh based on mr fox's report
that the essential test is not met
and the officer's recommendation is to
refuse
is fully justified
thank you councillor harvey councillor
fleming if you'd like to come in please
yeah thank you chairman um as a
as a person who designed and installed
agricultural grain handling machinery
for the best part of 30 years and also
as engineering manager of several big
grain
silos um there are problems that can
happen
with grain storage and i think everybody
is focusing on the fact that this is
about security
i think it's about the fact that you
have to have some kind of expertise
in knowledge in what you're doing in
terms of handling this equipment
and handling the grain and monitoring i
mean chris
kettles says a counselor kettles has
been saying about there is a lot of
monitoring equipment in modern grain
silos and there is
but you have to have somebody who can
react to that information
and to do the right thing with it a pure
security guard wouldn't have a clue to
do with a modern grain handling system
and we're expecting this farmer to do
this 365 24 7.
so i think it that that's an unfair
expectation anyway
but in reality um i can't see any reason
why we would refuse this particular
application
because i see it as an essential need
i know i'm sure i'm railing against
officers
and experts again but i've listened to
what mr wilden says
and it makes total common sense so from
that perspective
i wouldn't support um a refu i wouldn't
support a refuse uh decision on this one
thank you very much thank you council
fleming
does anybody else want to come in on on
this one
[Music]
right um that's been a long while
ago um have we uh
ross or olivia could you remind me was
it have we had a proposal on this one
and i'm not sure whether case the harvey
did i might be uh
no i didn't but i will
and i can second it mr chairman
so uh so the proposal is to go with
officer's recommendation is that right
cancer harvey
correct and you're happy to second that
catch the
mills did i hear you say you're quite
right mr chairman
right um i think we better go to the
vote then
yeah okay councillor crump
uh for councillor mills
council meals for councillor fielding
councillor fielding against
cancer fleming against councillor harvey
four councillor hentra serafin
against and cancer kettle
again chair that's
three four and four against
okay so therefore that file
so therefore we need a proposal
uh to we need somebody else to come up
with a proposal please
to
to grant the application with the
reasons
for granting the application
and we need some some planning reasons
john
why is every time i'm about to speak the
thing goes off um
basically i think we've got a basic
around as10
um where
it is it needs to have the security
element
that is referred to in
certain aspects of s10 i know it's
the one i quoted means that there was a
building on site before
but um the replace
develop of about a small scale expansion
of an existing mobile
partner that's not it permanent dwelling
for occupation by a person engaged in
agricultural operations
or other forms of use that can only
reasonably be carried out
in the countryside subject the
functional needs of the establishment
so as f
h i sorry would be one that i would go
for
so yeah and i think again so basically
you're saying
there is an essential need for a worker
to be permanently
present on site and that need
can't be met without providing a new
dwelling in a unsustainable countryside
location
yes and tied into the business as well
it should have an agricultural thai
placed on it
so okay it's not an open market
i just need to bring in alice alice can
you come in please
just for some clarification yes of
course thank you chairman
and thank you councillor fielding i
think the only thing i just wanted to
clarify just so members are aware
um the as-10 provides a number of
development management considerations
which guide how we interpret policy as
10
all the policies in the core strategy
have it in respect of part
i which um obviously relates to this
very point
um in terms of the the need for
for a dwelling for an agricultural
worker it does specifically state that a
case based solely on grounds of security
will not necessarily be sufficient
in terms of that essential need so i'm
not i'm not
um saying that you can't go with it but
i just wanted to make sure that members
were aware that the dmo specifically say
that security will
not necessarily be adequate
so it is also there to help with the
management as well as security
okay so um so i'm taking it at the
moment the the reason for grant is that
in light
of as10i uh
members consider that the security and
management needs
of the business justify a new dwelling
on the site
understanding that there's already a
dwelling there with the applicant living
in
um that that additional dwelling is
required and it's the only way
of um adequately addressing those needs
of the applicant
is that correct i agree okay
are you uh happy to agree with that
council kettle
uh yes i'm i'm happy with that i think
the
management issue is is fundamental to
this uh given the size of the operation
uh and given its proximity to to the
road to be honest
okay so um so cancer fielding
is proposed grant in this application
for the reasons just mentioned um
i'll be our secondary proposal
to that one um but i'm sure you won't be
offended
um right so we now need to go to the
vote
um just just on conditions chairman are
you
members happy for those to be delegated
to officers i've heard you say you want
the um
agricultural tie condition the rest of
the conditions are you happy for those
to be delegated to officers
yeah i'm happy are you happy that
i'm happy with that yeah right
um right so we'll go through the votes
olivia you're happy with that now
yeah um councillor cramp abstain
councillor mills
that's the hectic serotonin it's a
hentra seraphine four
and cancer cattle councillor kettle four
chair that's four four one against into
abstentions right committee resolves to
grant application twenty zero zero nine
sub mate full uh with conditions
uh delegated to officers um
uh probably in this association with
agreement with the chairman
so okay russ is that uh
yeah yeah
right so that
moves us on to the last item on the
agenda
which is urgent business do we vote to
extend it for another
no it's um
right any urgent business i don't
believe i've been notified
of anything so on declare
planning committee be for the
26 of august 2020
to be closed thank you